All right, so let's sort of close the loop
on our coverage of the Gates situation, I
told you last segment that Donald Trump had
to be talked out of publicly defending Matt
Gates because the believed allegations against
him are so serious.
Now, in the next segment, you will see that
Matt Gates is still claiming that he has support
from Donald Trump.
But breaking this morning, a report from CNN
that Matt Gates tried to meet with Donald
Trump and was denied such a meeting.
It seems as though Donald Trump has been thoroughly
convinced by his aides and staffers that Matt
Gates is completely toxic right now.
And actually, this fits very much within what
we know about Donald Trump.
And I'll get into that in a moment.
The report from CNN is that Congressman Matt
Gates, facing a federal investigation into
sex trafficking allegations, recently was
denied a meeting that he tried to get with
Donald Trump at Trump's Mar a Lago estate.
As Trump and allies continue to distance from
the Florida congressman, two people familiar
with the matter say that Gates tried to schedule
a visit with Donald Trump after it was revealed
that he was being investigated.
But the request was rejected by aides close
to Donald Trump, who, as I mentioned to you
in the previous segment, are telling Trump,
don't stick your neck out for this guy.
Don't defend Matt Gates.
Harlan Hill, who is a spokesman for Gates,
is denying it and saying no such meeting was
requested.
And that actually Gates was welcomed to Trump
Doral this weekend and didn't try to meet
with Donald Trump.
Now, my instinct is that this is, of course,
if you are if you're Matt Gates, you request
the meeting through staff.
And if it's rejected, the staff simply deny
having requested it.
And if you're Matt Gates, you can accurately
say, I never requested anything.
So if you say, well, how do I adjudicate the
differences between the claims that are being
made?
It's it's quite obvious to me that this is
exactly what the way it would work if indeed,
Matt Gates quietly tried to get the meeting
and it was rejected.
CNN writes that the interference by Trump's
aides signals that Gates is increasingly isolated
as he weathers a potentially career ending
scandal just months after he offered to leave
his job to join Trump's impeachment defense
team.
Comedically, Gates joining the impeachment
defense team may have been more substantive
as far as you know, like Saturday Night Live
writers are concerned, but this may actually
be a much more interesting sort of going down
in flames for Matt Gates.
Now, you'll also remember that last week it
was revealed and reported that Matt Gates
tried to get a blanket preemptive pardon from
Donald Trump at the end of Donald Trump's
presidency that has also been denied by Donald
Trump.
Trump claiming Gates did not ask me for a
pardon.
Again, with all of these things, it's possible
that Gates staffers went to Trump staffers
and said, would this work?
Trump staffers would have said he's not going
to do that.
And as far as Trump knows, it was never an
official request.
And so nobody is really lying.
But the spirit of this is that Gates did want
the pardon.
That's often, you know, in political speak,
the way this is all orchestrated is to have
that plausible deniability.
Trump can say, I was never asked to pardon
him and that can be true.
While it can also be true that Gates directed
staff to fill out Trump staff as to whether
it's something that might be possible.
Now, the other kind of question about the
meeting being denied between Gates and Trump
is that Gates was at this event in Florida,
and although he didn't meet privately with
Trump, you would think that that has some
meaning, that he was still sort of allowed
to participate at the other on the other end.
What can Trump really even do for Gates at
this point?
I mean, it seems that at this point the story
is so out of the bag, either Republican's
big picture are just going to start ignoring
it.
And Matt Gates will be able to survive this
and won't have to resign or Gates is basically
going to be done for.
But beyond just repeating the same lies that
Gates is telling, I don't really know what
Trump can do for Gates at this point in time
when Trump was president.
Lying about himself to some degree worked
in another sense it didn't, because Trump
lost and he lost the House for Republicans
and he lost the Senate, but it at least kept
Trump afloat amidst some scandals.
Trump as a former president, telling lies
in defense of Matt Gates.
It's not really clear to me that it would
do very much.
Now, one last thought on this before we move
on to what Matt Gates is actually saying about
all of these things.
Loyalty is a one way street with Donald Trump.
Matt Gates was completely loyal to a sort
of disgusting, sycophantic level during Trump's
presidency.
But Gates is no longer useful to Donald Trump.
Once you're no longer useful to Trump or you
have your own problems, Trump tosses you aside
like he's done to so many people in his life.
Eventually, it's always just a matter of time.
So that's the latest from Trump.
Let's now look at some of the very strange
things that Matt Gates said